when you spoke about the money printing
press where we become
reliant on the daddy state the daddy
state that will give us lots of money
and we don't need to work and we don't
need to worry about anything because the
printing press will just
give us more money i recently released a
video called
printing press goes bur bitcoin goes
boom and
what i'm talking about in that video is
the more money that the printing press
pumps out
the more people are forced into a harder
money such as bitcoin
whether they like bitcoin or not it's in
two ways what i'm finding now is people
are shifting into bitcoin not because
they think they can buy a lamborghini
but because there's no other choice it
is now at a point that
if you keep your money in cash it's
becoming it's becoming a liability it's
financially irresponsible to not at
least have some bitcoin
as people are fleeing out of the us
dollar and trying to run
to a new money which is bitcoin what are
your thoughts on the future of money if
america keeps printing it
and america keeps pushing everyone into
a corner to go a certain way
and people do flee the states at a
national level and then at a federal
level going somewhere else
when will it stop do you think there
could be a war on the horizon
oh i mean of course i mean look look at
one of the things right now with bitcoin
they're trying to find out how to
regulate bitcoin janet yellen is trying
to do whatever she can to get a hold of
bitcoin for five years
if you see anybody asking about bitcoin
watch what's been my biggest concern
every single time they're going to try
to regulate it they're going to try to
regulate it they're going to try to
regulate it that's the biggest thing
because that's what the government likes
to do they like to regulate gold they
like to regulate bitcoin they like to
regulate
anything and everything they can get
their hands on to administrate so
um i don't know i think i can tell you
one thing for a fact
is today if there's ever been an era
where all the bitcoin people
are laughing saying i told you so
today's the day like
all the bitcoin pro bitcoin people ought
to go on twitter and say i told you so
hashtag bitcoin they have the right to
do so because
they can say that today now
remember how earlier i talked to you
about the most dangerous people you'll
ever face are lazy ambitious people
yeah regulators and politicians are
exactly that
they're the lazy ambitious people they
hate the fact that you came up with an
idea that you don't need somebody to
take care of you they hate the fact that
you don't need
a guy in your pocket to finance your
election or whatever your campaign they
hate the fact that
they're not willing to work seven to ten
o'clock at night to build a business and
go sell it for a hundred million dollars
five years later or ten years later for
a billion dollars
they hate that because they're not going
to do that that's not what they're going
to do
so what do they do do they go behind
closers and say i'm going to go get
power
you want all the freedom i'm going to be
able to push you around because i'll
have the power
i make the laws i'm the lawmaker and i
can make laws to make your life
a living hell that's how they do it
so bitcoin's biggest enemy is going to
be
the lawmakers the politicians
governments that are going to want to
get into it
the benefit i hope elon musk supports
you guys and stays that way doesn't go
back and forth doesn't kind of like
because you guys need a very strong
supporter
on your end to prevent these other guys
from getting away the good news right
now is jp morgan chase just officially
put
35 or 34 job postings online
for people that are experts in
blockchain and you know quite frankly
morgan stanley only put two and goldman
sachs only put two but jp morgan chase
put 3435 about he's like
wait what jp morgan is hiring 34
blockchain experts yes
why well they're coming out with their
own bitcoin so the more these stories
happens then you have the allies
when it gets to a point where they're
facing off the enemies
that's where you benefit but you have to
also be thinking about
if they come out with their own crypto
say jpmorgan chase comes out with their
own crypto
do you think behind closed doors they
would support some of the politicians to
hurt the bitcoin brand because they're
not bitcoin they're a different crypto
i don't know all i'm saying to you is
you have to pay
very very close attention to the
lawmakers and the lazy ambitious people
because they're the ones that are
probably going to try to make your life
a living kill